okay is your person a man you know they
they might be gender non-binary okay hmm
you don't you go okay is your person
assist straight white probably skin
edict cog in the machine of the
suffocating heteronormative patriarchal
misogynistic value tripping
judeo-christian military-industrial
complex I mean I don't I don't think
he's white but I'm not sure like I
shouldn't assume yeah yeah oh okay okay
is your person wearing any sort of
accessory I mean are we including
procedures meant to protect the gender
nonconforming from hate speech based
solely on appearance Hey I just meant
like earrings
oh no okay yes babe a two down here we
go okay all right is your person yes
okay you know what I think we're good
here
yeah yeah I feel good I feel good I had
max I had Anita
so um good game I'll see you later
bye-bye
[Music]